hey I need everybody to clear out
is we've already tested shopping carts
and we've tested door dings today we're
going to get a chance to test the actual
bullet performance so when we first
started the design for cybertruck the
goal was to come up with something that
had an exoskeleton we had to make a
custom alloy to make it more ductile
while we're at it we also made it a bit
more corrosion resistant so this is a
300 series our panels are up to 1.8 mm
thick so actually carrying structural
load not just there for Aesthetics
obviously we didn't design it to be
bulletproof but if it works out in the
end it's just icing on the cake so we've
got a couple guns here to go through
starting with a 9mm Glock shotgun double
op buck and of course Tommy Gun 45
caliber so we'll get all these through
tested today and we'll see the results
range is
hot
[Music]
clear I was really nervous it's hard to
say how nervous I was but it worked out
we we took a Tommy Gun to the side of
this truck and everything looks intact
all right moment of
truth it's pretty good this one
intense apprciate that yes
[Laughter]
happy so that's 9 mm 115 grain from a
Glock looking pretty good we got one
spot where we got a double hit and so
we've got a little bit of cracking but
everywhere else we've just got a
crater looks
good
all right so this was an MP5 it's the
same 9mm 115 grain it's going a bit
faster we've got only a 4-in barrel but
an 8 in suppressor on that so you can
kind of see obviously a bit more tighter
of grouping but um yeah still no
penetration so looking
good this is a 12 gauge M4 shotgun with
double op
Buck took five
rounds held up pretty well we had one
where we' got two of the buck shots hit
right in the same spot got a bit of a
through hole there let's see it made it
all the way
through well the inside of the panel is
good there's no hole here let's see
about the
glass yeah we got a little crack in the
glass but it held
all the windows are intact everything
functions just as it did when we started
here so I call it a
success so don't believe the movies when
you shoot a normal truck the bullets go
in one side straight through and out the
other side you cannot hide behind the
vehicle to be safe so it's something to
keep in mind unless you're in a cyber
truck